[Music]
[Music]
all right short dance because this is a
long-form interview when people want to
get to it people want to hear him you
can follow him on the Twitter you know
him on YouTube stefan molyneux free
domain radio is what the channel is on
youtube but he has a new book out show
that that book for people who haven't
seen there you go it is the art of the
argument so stefan molyneux and i will
be talking here today full show before
we people complain we're the photos and
if we don't do a full long-form show
with a guest they people also complain
sometimes but thanks for being here sir
oh it's my pleasure I also wanted to
thank you for the blurb and just remind
people the full name is the art of the
argument Western civilization's
last stand and you can find it at the
art of the argument calm we got audio
book coming up we got Kindle we got
print we got everything we'll get it
tattooed on your forehead it's obviously
gonna be a fairly small font yeah well
once I get past the add the colon on
most these titles I can't remember all
of them I just I want to get them the
general concept of the book in and then
I figure the author will know better hey
um are you gonna read the audiobook
yourself yes I already have so what is
this accent I've always wondered because
it's kind of a cross I know you're
raised in Canada but it's like this
amalgamation if it almost if you
listened it could sound partially South
Africa and it kind of sounds English and
Canadian what created this before we get
to the actual substance of the book well
that's a number of things so first I was
born in Ireland but lived there for a
very short amount of time and then I
grew up in England till I was 11 I
visited my father lived in South Africa
visited there I came to Canada went back
to South Africa for a little while and
of course the challenges as well if you
don't have a cool British accent your
sexual market value depends on you yes
and so clearly I didn't want to do that
I didn't want to take that approach so
tried to milk the accent for all I could
and then what happened was I went to the
National Theatre School and if I just
didn't want to do Shakespeare for the
rest of my life I needed to find a way
to drop the accent so I tried to take it
out back and shoot it in the neck that
had sort of various degrees of success
and basically I just gave up and left
the language work for itself but it is a
bit of a tour of the colonies Acts and
it's kind of tough to nail down and it
does drive people rather mad when they
try and figure out what the hell's going
on there you
actually I didn't know all those things
but I knew it wasn't Canadian and the
good thing is any accent is better for
picking up chicks then the Canadian
accent states it and well southern
accent yeah southern accent if you
because you can do the Matthew
McConaughey kind of make it a little
second role there's nothing sexy about
the maritime sound when you're out there
in the States so I'm too lazy to rise
above a vocal fry yeah okay yeah
although they'll never believe them if
they come up with some sort of like
disease cure no one believes someone
with a southern accent you can kind of
be charming but we're not trusting you
with any medical advancements no really
I'm a physicist yes all right so stefan
molyneux art of the argument that was
this the title it has been the working
title for a long time because obviously
art of the deal is it a play on that or
they just happen to have the same it was
just sort of an inspiration based on
that and you know I've been debating
with people since I was a little kid I
was on the debating team I was the fifth
best debater in Canada the first year I
tried it and really really enjoyed it
and I don't know I guess you go through
at least I went through a whole series
of maybe if I just have better
information maybe if I just have better
arguments maybe if I just have better
analogies I can actually work to change
people's minds but as you try that in
the world as you've tried as I tried and
what was some success but I think I just
finally came down to the idea that I'm
not sure that people really know what an
argument is I'm not sure they really
know how important it is and I'm not
sure in fact I'm fairly sure they really
don't know how to do it which is a shame
because when we're kids all we do is
argue you know write argue but the
friends we argue with our parents we
argue with our teachers if they'll let
us we we argue just about everything
which is great it's how you sharpen your
verbal wits and have an influence in the
world that's peaceful and positive but
man does that ever get scrubbed out of
us over the course of our childhood and
particularly I think when you get into
you know high school and college well I
think and you talk about this in your
book I think it's because an argument is
misconstrued it's somehow seen is
impolite when that's not actually what
an argument is so you sort of your quote
to become a meme of that's not an
argument I'm sure you know about that so
for the audience give us give us sort of
a briefing what is an argument I know
you define it in the book so I want out
there if you feel as though this was
informative don't say I got the
cliffnotes go buy the book but
let's introduce um what is an argument
fine all right page one so what an
argument is when you try to change
someone's mind with reason and evidence
and that really you know they do you
think that's impolite boy you should see
the alternatives it's like arcing piss
bottles and it's like Spears going into
the sides of horses and it's like
setting fire to Baltimore I mean yeah
the alternative to the argument is worse
than anything you can conceive of you
know we emerge from this primitive head
climbing suit head clubbing Society
2,500 years ago we got the Socratic
method and we've been battling between
you know violence and reason ever since
and right now think we're teetering a
little bit on the brink and the goal of
course is try and tip it in the favor of
the argument because that's where
civilization really resides have you
been reading about when you did your
research on this book because we've
written about this at the web site have
you been reading about how the Socratic
method depending on the university is
seen as discriminatory some schools
actually obviously because it's been
replaced with different types of
liberation theology x' insert blank
liberation theology here but I was
surprised because I never learned it in
university I never learned Socratic
method I had to learn it on my own there
were a lot of things that I didn't learn
in school
it seems no you should be learning that
in like grade four you should be
learning that in grade 3 I mean as a as
a father you know my daughter is
incredibly logical and is able to
pinpoint but like laser accuracy when
I'm making a slightly inconsistent
statement it's like Oh father you said
something quite contradictory to this
whoa not seven and a half months ago by
my childlike calendar and therefore your
argument is an old sir I say and now
she's wearing it just a judge rigged up
to the kids table and they she's mature
so I mean I think we naturally born to
to argue and to debate and go back and
forth and and you know you get a bunch
of kids after Halloween you sit him
around a table and you watch him wheel
and deal and negotiate back and forth
again about who gets what candy and so
on I mean it's like watching a bunch of
boxers on speed it's incredible yeah and
this really gets scrubbed out of us to
the point where we all want to have an
effect on the world we all want to
change the world to the better or at
least according to our own ideology how
are we going to go about doing it well
we can run to the government we could
say pass a damn law suppress these
people you know we can call up
advertisers and say well you shouldn't
you shouldn't advertise with these
people because they're terrible we can
throw bricks at people we can you know
try and get people delisted from their
websites and so on but I think we really
do want to have reason and evidence and
the idea that it's somehow related to
gender or race it's just another way to
to divide us I mean reason and evidence
are universal across the planet across
humanity and so on and the idea that
somehow you know it's white privilege to
be rational that's kind of an insult to
everyone else and not much of a
compliment to white people yeah well we
were talking about this when we did our
hour I guess you'd call it I don't know
undercover investigative work in Houston
it's this peer pressure straw man it's
this outrage ponzi-scheme from the left
and that's what they want to silence
dialogue that's what they said well gay
people are offended black people are
offended in the truth is the people most
marginalizing these groups are the
leftists they're the ones who are
marginalizing them I watched my friend
Owen Benjamin do stand-up recently and
he has some racially tinged humor and
the people laughing the hardest were
black people in the audience because it
wasn't mean-spirited it seems as though
offense and and taking a front to an
argument is very much conditioned they
say racism is conditioned people don't
hate people just based on the color skin
that's absolutely true just as far as
melanin and skin if you look at that
tweet from Barack Obama which oh okay I
see it too black kid and white can plan
together what what how is this news but
this idea of taking offense to an
argument is very much conditioned and
it's liberals doing that you weren't
always I guess sort of right-wing if I'm
not mistaken you talk a lot about moral
relativism and absolutism kind of define
the difference for us and did that play
a part maybe in your transition
certainly in becoming more active
politically well yeah I mean the the
left since we happen to be talking about
them the laugh continually says you know
there's no such thing as truth
everything is relative and so on which
of course if you take that at face value
and I've known a few of these horror
slash freak shows of soulless people in
my life who say everything is relative
there's no such thing as truth there's
no such thing as virtue so then shut up
about it you know that would be the
thing you know like middle-earth doesn't
exist so I'm not gonna start up a travel
agency to get you there it's like
there's no such thing as truth then shut
up there's
such thing as virtue then shut up if
there's no such thing as virtue there's
no such thing as truth then there should
be no such thing as racism there should
be no such thing as you know right or
wrong behavior in any context no such
thing as sexism no such thing as a
negative power disparity or anything but
they say wow there's no truth there's no
reason there's no evidence there's no
logic there's no virtue but let me
instruct you as a violent micromanager
exactly how to lift your life in
conformity with my ideology it's like
when you gotta pick one man I mean right
just got to pick one or the other but
they of course want all the benefits of
relativism which means you don't have to
define your own position with all the
benefits of moralizing which means you
get to finger wag at others yes I mean
this is a group of people not gay Jared
Eric every now and then he stumbles
across a brilliant point he said they
would have all nonviolent drug offenders
out of jail but people who use the word
[ __ ] in maximum-security prisons now I'm
not saying that nonviolent drug
offenders should be in jail but I'm
saying at some point they draw a line
and for them it's hate speech you'd need
to be jailed for hate speech but if
you're dealing crack I will give you a
pass at some point there has to be a
judgement call
so let's kind of walk through because
you coach people in this book you teach
them how to make arguments how to form
arguments before we kind of get into
some examples because I know you're very
good at this what would you say is most
important for people to know when they
are framing an argument well there is
the fundamental question of what is your
argument for and and who is its intended
audience so I mean if you're just
debating with someone of the internet
that's not quite as important if you're
more public facing person I think it's
it's important know why it's important
to you you know that the first
commandment of Socrates was know thyself
know why something's important you know
why you care about something because if
you're emotionally triggered man it's
really hard to make a cohesive and
rational argument and it is so easy to
fly off the handle and get offended
understand why it's important for the
other person you know what why are we
even having this debate what does it
even matter otherwise you know it's kind
of this random shadow punching where
it's designed to mask an emotional
investment rather than the pursuit of
reason itself so I think that
self-knowledge is really important that
once you've got that squared away you
need to know that your argument is
rational you need to know what is the
what are the principles behind it what
is the evidence
that supports it and you have to
strenuously avoid imposing conclusions
on people you know when you smile white
privilige racism sexist this is all
these are all just conclusions they're
just designed to blood you err bludgeon
you into submission you've got to build
the case up slowly I mean you you you
you wouldn't be a very good lawyer if
you you know you jump into court remand
just scream guilty guilty guilty guilty
over and over yeah the other guy's
innocent innocent innocent it's like
you've got to build the case you're
gonna call your witnesses you got to
present your evidence you've got to
build the case if you build the case
slowly and carefully getting agreement
every step of the way the conclusion
should be reached by your audience
almost before you provided to them and
when they own that conclusion having
followed your reasoning process they're
much more likely to stick with it you
can sort of browbeat someone into
compliance in the moment but you know
it's just like holding a balloon
underwater you let go walk away a pop-up
it comes right just on that note before
we get into some examples because like
you said white privilege this idea of I
don't know patriarchy these are
conclusions is it an exercise in
futility to argue with somebody who is
using those conclusions as arguments
themselves do you need to just recognize
alright there's there's no reason to try
and argue this because they're just
hitting me with a conclusion this isn't
going anywhere I you know I I I hear
what you're saying and there are
certainly times when that is the case I
view most of the people who are making
bad arguments in society at the moment
Steve as ignorant not malevolent yes you
know there is this an old I don't go as
far as there's an old argument out of
ancient Greek philosophy which says that
all evil is a form of ignorance that if
they just if evil people knew how good
benefited them and how evil harms them
and so on that they would become good
people I don't go that far I think there
are genuinely malevolent souls in the
world but I view most people as as
misguided they've been badly informed
they've been programmed by a bunch of
power-hungry Sophists they have been
kind of set up as attack dogs on anyone
who raises relevant questions and you
know forgive them father as the saying
goes they know not what they do
so IDEs to me if someone starts jumping
at me with conclusions it's like okay
well let's step back and tell me how you
got there where was the where does the
argument start from and how do you deal
with this contradictory information and
so on you know the old Donald Trump
a fascist you know if he was a real
fascist you'd be in jail already no the
fact that you can call him a fascist how
do you square that with the idea that
he's supposedly this fashion's also what
is fascism how do you define it how is
it distinguished from the fruit of the
free market how is it distinguished from
communism or socialism or a mixed
economy and very quickly you'll find out
this is again back to Socrates who
questioned all of the supposedly wise
people of his day and found that they
really didn't know anything they just
pretended to know stuff and most people
are out there you know thumping their
chests and hurling these language bombs
of people they really don't know what
they're doing which is one thing but
they don't even know that they don't
know what they're doing
and when you'd point that out to people
some people will escalate but some
people would be like huh I guess I
thought that was true but I'm not sure I
really have the argument down pat what a
wonderful opportunity to engage in a
productive dialogue yeah I think that's
a great point talking about how there
are some truly malevolent Souls but it's
generally not the rule I've always
talked about this how there are people
like you said who are ignorant and there
are people who are so dead set in their
ways it doesn't matter that's why when I
interviewed someone in Hawaii his name
was Wil Corona said listen what if I
could provide you with let's say five
sources we both agreed upon that an $18
minimum wage or a universal basic income
of $1,500 a month has negative
ramifications on the lower class and
middle class if I could provide you with
irrefutable evidence would you look at
the other side and he said you know what
yeah I would ask someone else that same
question they said well I would figure
out how to make it work and so sometimes
you've got to recognize okay this is
someone whose mind can be changed that's
your audience someone whose mind cannot
the audience is the people who might see
this argument it's the actual audience
of the argument and I think you do a
good job of recognizing the difference
there so okay let's pick I don't know if
you've a specific topic that you would
like to pick to go through an example do
you have one that you want to because
I'm happy to if you've got an argument
that keeps arising in your mind or in
your interactions with people I'm happy
to look at that as well you know what
I'm not very good at this this is it's I
did a public speaking a persuasive I
guess persuasive essay but in public
speaking so I don't know if you call
that and the persuasive oral I'm not
exactly what showed of us but in Canada
they had these international
competitions and I just happen to do it
in my class and then I was ranked top in
the province I didn't even know until
after it happened and they put me down
and it was actually about Quebec so
awful film rating system everything I
don't remember well you're from on that
you were in Ontario and Quebec
everything was pg-13 was gee unless
there was a single gunshot then I was PG
16 so Jerry Maguire gee Dangerous Minds
gee like you could basically see porn
and it was gee it would come in and BG
and then all of a sudden it would be an
action film that was pg-13 in the States
and was PG 16 I didn't oral on that and
then they asked me to join the debate
club and I said well yeah sure and I
left immediately when I was told that I
had to argue things I didn't believe in
I wasn't very good at it and I know
that's that's a that's a skill that's
learned in debate but I said I I don't
really have time for this especially in
Quebec because I had to argue right off
the bat for third trimester abortions
for yeah I was like no okay so I'm not
very money if you're a sports team don't
you study the other teams plays
obsessively to figure out what they're
doing I do what I don't know that I can
I guess because I don't believe it and
because we work in this and I'd like to
think there's there's I'd like to think
this show is based on sincerity I feel
like people can smell it on you so
forgive me if I don't do a very
convincing job from the opposition you
know obviously I'm sorry and I just
wanted to point out like as a mental
exercise it's a great idea but you
wouldn't want people to think that's
your real position you could say you
know devil's advocate position right on
giving the other position and so on but
you don't want people like if you're
really really good at advocating for a
position that you don't believe in
people get a little goose like whoa hang
on a second yeah he's really good at
this stuff and has no fixed positions if
he can so I think it's good to do that
publicly to show that you can understand
the mind of an opponent but you wouldn't
want people to mistake that for your
real position okay how about one here
then this that's nuanced the Confederate
statues that's one that we've been
running into a lot and I could I can see
some different perspectives on it
obviously I have my own opinions but all
right so do you want to start this off
or should I just let you know that I
think you're an idiot because and begin
argument okay so there's a number of
different ways you can approach this
argument to do with the Confederate
statues one of the more libertarian
arguments would be to say but the
problem is that these are all public
spaces and publicly funded statues you
know there's a statue in Seattle of
Lenin and my understanding is it's on
private property well I make it you're
making the argument on the other side
let me do the bad argument yeah let me
do the argument of the others
all right Stefan hey listen an tyfa has
to tear down these statues need to be
all torn down because listen there are
black people in united states to them
these statues robert e lee represent a
side of american history who supported
slavery and since there are taxpayer
dollars at play we cannot place these in
public spaces that might honor these
figures how could you be against that
stefan molyneux okay so this is the
point now when you are faced with an
argument the initial impulse from most
people is to rush right down into the
thickets and start debating about this
particular issue right that is not
philosophical and that is going to be
very destructive for a slide in the long
run as a whole what you need to do is
say ok let's forget about the specific
content of what is being talked about
and let's extract it to a principle so
then I would say so what is the
principle at play is the principle at
play here that if you find something
offensive it should be removed from your
sight no I'm not saying if something is
merely offensive but when we are using
public spaces as places of honor of
American history it is not conducive
toward moving forward progressively in
the United States to creating a better
history for the future by honoring
people who supported barbaric practices
like slavery and by honoring people who
fought against right now these free
United States who ended up winning right
so then the question is is it
necessarily that the statues imply an
advocacy or an honor of slavery or are
they merely important historical figures
whose presence we need to be reminded of
I mean I don't think there are any
inscriptions that say this guy was
horrible he beat his slaves and that's
the very best thing you could possibly
hope for
in a society if we're gonna have a
principle called anything which
according to current moral standards in
the past didn't meet those moral
standards we should erase it and curious
what part of history you would retain so
for instance Martin Luther King jr.
fantastic preacher a very passionate man
fought in the civil rights movement
severely and significantly and deeply
opposed
gay marriage now this was not unusual
for him in the day there has been an
evolution in some ways of acceptance of
homosexual practices in Western society
should we then go back and say well
according to current standards he's
homophobic and therefore he must be
erased from history how is it we're
gonna possibly end up with any history
because then what happens is every moral
advancement it races everything that
came before it and we end up as a tree
with no roots whatsoever playing devil's
advocate here for people who are tuning
in late okay
no I don't think that that's necessarily
a fair comparison because Martin Luther
King was not recognized for his
opposition to same-sex marriage he was
recognized for his being a you know
being obviously a pioneer in the civil
rights of the United States which I
think most people would agree is
productive these statues that we are
talking about these people are mainly
known for fighting in battle for the
side that fought for slavery who fought
for the Confederacy and I think that at
the very least we should certainly as it
relates to taxpayer dollars take them
out of public parks where people might
find them very offensive as that could
directly be an affront to black
Americans who have a very different
history and put them in their
appropriate places in museums so I'm not
saying let's get rid of them completely
I just don't think that it's necessarily
appropriate considering what they were
most known historically for so as a
couple of points there the first thing
is that it's still highly debatable
whether the civil war was directly
around slavery right there's lots of
people who make very strong arguments
with a lot of supporting evidence that
say that the the secession of the South
had a lot more to do with the perceived
Federalist tyranny of Lincoln and the
imposition of brutal taxation on the
south and the feeling that the Union was
not providing the south anywhere close
to what it was taking out of the south
so there's no specific conclusion around
that and this is why the debate needs to
be kept alive I think that's one
important point we want to make sure
that we keep these things around so that
we continue to have these debates and
further examine and explore the history
of America and what makes America
America in the present so that's one
thing that I would say the second thing
that I would say is that I don't think
it's possible for any one individual to
speak
for an entire community so for instance
there are many studies which show that
the majority of black people support
having these statues remain around as
part of the history as part of the
legacy as a reminder sometimes of how
bad history can go and a way of making
sure that it nothing gets repeated in
the same way again so the idea that
there are a few blacks who get very
upset and offended by this should again
we get back to this point in principle
should people's offense be enough to
remove history from people's sight well
I think particularly we're not talk
about removing them from people's sight
we're talking devil's advocate we're
talking about putting them into museums
where it might be more appropriate so
that we are very clear you know for
example we have Nazi paraphernalia in
museums we don't put them up in public
parks we want to make sure this is put
an appropriate place where people can
study it for history but also study it
for the stain that it was in American
history and I understand that maybe what
perhaps we could find some common ground
here where there were many in the
Confederacy including some black people
who fought for the Confederacy who were
not necessarily fighting for slavery but
they were fighting for as you talk about
it states rights a different view of
sort of maybe a Hamiltonian approach to
the United States government however at
the end of the day it still does go back
to the the Constitution it still does go
back to Liberty to not being able to own
somebody else as a human being and
whether all supported that or not the
Confederacy it was a part of their
battle to ensure that they maintained
that right to subjugate another human
being I think we all would have to agree
that that would have been a very
different fabric for America a toxic
fabric and maybe we can find common
ground where we say okay let's allow the
monuments of people who fought for the
Confederacy but we're expressly against
slavery let's exclude those perhaps we
could agree on removing statues of
people who actively supported the
continued practice of slavery so then
the argument is that people who actively
supported slavery should be removed from
public view and should be placed in some
sort of pay wall basically you've got a
you've got a a museum which people have
to pay usually to to go in to see so
it's kind of out of sight out of mind
now the question of course around
slavery is very complicate
as part of sort of as it relates to
American history number one of course is
that only like four or five percent of
southerners actually own slaves the vast
majority of southerners really really
disliked the practice of slavery the the
poor of whites and poor blacks of course
those who had freed the poor whites
really hated slavery because it drove
down the price of labor it was in a
sense you know a very extreme form of
illegal or I guess in this case legal
immigration to drive down wages so they
really disliked that also of course
southern whites were conscripted like
forced into slave hunting gangs they had
to give up like you know a couple of
nights a month or sometimes even more to
trudge around the wilderness looking for
escaped slaves so they disliked it
enormous Lee there were a number of
vivere first slave owner in the south
was a black man and there were a number
of blacks who owned slaves and it wasn't
just because they were owning family
members who had been freed there was of
course the robust practice of slave
ownership this complexity is something
that needs to be discussed and needs to
be talked about and if you scrub the
history of a country away because of a
one-dimensional interpretation of what
those statues mean you diminish a robust
examination of the past that is
necessary to develop a nuance of how the
country got to where it got to and of
course it was successful it was
successful the the fight to end slavery
around the world was achieved in the
19th century by the British Empire by by
Lincoln and others and so I don't know
that we should necessarily get rid of
all of that history and and move it
behind a paywall we need to have it back
out there so the people can have these
kinds of discussions and recognize that
it's not simple I hate to say it black a
simple black and white issue stefan
molyneux are you a racist no Han I don't
want to I don't want to make it out here
well okay so let me understand this that
your premise is that it's productive for
these to be on public display for people
to have discussions what if I were to
present the idea that let's say in a
city where this was this is a monument
to a very insidious slave owner who this
was one of his main purposes in the
civil war he actively fought for slavery
was clear it was well known and if there
were a vote if there were statistics
that would reflect that black people
felt very uncomfortable felt very much
as though this was a symbol of a
oppression if our goal as you say is to
have these conversations is there a
certain point where it actually creates
toxicity and we could agree there are
instances where something should be done
well I mean I hate to pull out the old
slippery slope argument but I'm afraid
it does really apply here so if there's
some guys you point out you know he was
pro-slavery he owned slaves he was a bad
guy all around well that's part of the
history of the country that's part of
the history in the environment and again
that provokes discussions about you know
how far America has come how maybe how
far it still has to go in terms of being
race neutral in its laws and attitudes
and so on but that is part of the
history obviously the guy's not gonna
come back to life and kidnap a bunch of
people and stuff them in the back of his
metal carriage or anything like that so
there's no particular threat as far as
that goes
I can't laughter that's why here is the
slippery slope argument which is okay so
George Washington owed slaves Thomas
Jefferson owned slaves you could kind of
go do we get rid of Mount Rushmore do we
get rid of Monticello do we get rid of
the white house the white house was
built in part by slave labor this is the
history of the country and my concern in
particular is that if you start to cave
on this kind of stuffs they've open
going to remove this and we're gonna
remove that history shows in particular
it never stops it only continues to
escalate because it emboldened people
who want to scrub a country of its
history and of course the point is as
well that when you allow people to start
focusing on historical statues what
happens is it distracts them in many
ways from the far more pressing issues
that are going on in the present in
terms of race relations in terms of you
know black opportunity in terms of black
poverty black crime rates black
legitimacy and so on we want to have
people focus on the present pretending
that the biggest issue facing minority
communities is the presence of statues
put up 120 years ago I think is entirely
playing into the hands of people who
want to distract productive solutions in
the here and now well I don't think I
would disagree there are certainly
issues plaguing minorities that need to
be addressed right now namely right-wing
racism but let me use a slippery slope
argument against you if you say well
it's a slippery slope to start taking
these down
could I not say it's a slippery slope to
allow these up why not stop why stop
with the Confederacy why not allow
monuments if people feel comfortable
with with fascists with dictators with
people who could be a part of we have
step monuments that aren't necessarily
exclusive to American history but world
history in our parks and our federal
parks across the country what's to stop
us from having a statue of Hitler or a
statue of a kamikaze bomber from World
War two the slippery slope could go both
ways well I mean the slippery slope
argument is fine unless you have well
over a century of empirical data saying
it's not happening right I mean we have
these statues that were put up and they
were put up of course remember after the
Civil War about six hundred thousand
dead entire states half in ruins and on
fire and starving the statues were put
up as a means of bringing unity back to
a shattered and divided country and the
fact that people who want to further
divide this country or divide America
are now wanting to pull down these
statues I don't think is accidental but
in the time since more and more of these
statues have not been put up statues of
the Kaiser statues of Hitler of
Mussolini of of Chairman Mao I guess
other than Lenin the one in Seattle on
private property these have not been
popping up so the slippery slope
argument in terms of the destruction of
history we see the totalitarian regimes
totalitarian mindsets mindsets are
continually scrubbing history from a
country I mean look at how Isis goes
into a Christian a region and it
destroys the churches and desecrates the
the monuments and so on and the
crucifixion scenes so this is very
common this happens all the time and
never stops until all history is
completely erased so that slippery slope
argument has lots of empirical data the
slippery slope argument in the other way
that next thing you know there's gonna
be you know giant batwing Satan's on the
top of the Capitol actually that might
be appropriate at times if the the idea
that the slippery slope argument is
going to go the other way
doesn't seem to have any empirical data
and the second point which is much more
brief Steve is there is is this I'll
tell you this not a fan of Hitler not a
fan of Mussolini not a fan of Chairman
Mao but if there's a strong enough
contingent
in America that people are passing out
the the Hat they're getting donations
they're commissioning an artist they're
getting the public land they're pushing
it through some sort of committee and
let's say you end up with some giant
statue of Mussolini yes I know some
people think I could pose for it but if
you end up with a big giant statue of
Mussolini I think that's kind of
important information to know about the
political leanings of those people in
your country who are willing to go that
far if you shut it down if you don't
ever allow it then the if there are
growing mussolini loving fascists in
your neck of the woods well they're just
gonna meet underground and then you're
not gonna be able to keep track of them
it's kind of like a free speech issue a
statue is kind of like a free speech
frozen thing it is not necessarily an
endorsement I mean somebody could put up
a statue of Hitler which provokes
discussion while being no fan of Hitler
almost Lee or anything like that but the
question fundamentally comes down to the
public space issue if it's private
property
then there's gonna be much less a
disagreement and you know in my opinion
in the West there's far too much public
property and far too much political
wrangling is about this kind of stuff so
the issue may go a lot deeper just in
terms of how much land and how many
resources the government owns versus it
being in private hands where these kinds
of issues are much less likely to arise
I see no need to continue an argument
with a right-wing racist who says that
he wants to erect a statue of Mussolini
I win the argument it was hard if people
could tweet me at s crowd are you at
stefan molyneux I don't know how I did I
was I was trying to [ __ ] it's I was
trying to beacon somewhat convincing
these are the arguments I would often
run into right no and see here's the
thing too we can have a productive
discussion you know you had some great
points evil Steve very eagle someone's
gonna take that and mash it up you know
to go by the way did you know that like
the evil Kirk but no I mean see we can
have a very productive discussion just
going back and forth we can both
illuminate each other's arguments of
course we can let the audience decide
but this is how things can work when
you're not just out there taking the
offense and escalating and screaming at
people I mean you could actually have a
very productive discussion and both end
up wiser I mean you brought up a bunch
of points well this was a surprise
debate which
right I'm certainly no deep expert on
the spi by the way for people who watch
and that was just a surprise I just
picked one because it happens to be in
the air right now and I actually do
think it's an issue with with more
nuance and I think I think if I were to
take a pro-abortion stance or something
that you'd it'd be very easy for you so
I tried to pick one that might be
complicated
no and it's very timely and so you are
for me at least you're always trying to
extract from the immediate emotions and
examples of the moment you know because
the false equivalency or the I guess the
false argument is something like this
well if you defend the existence or the
presence of statues of people who
defended slavery why you must be pro
slavery right and that of course is not
the argument at all and with philosophy
you do have to work very hard to extract
the principles yeah and if you extract
the principles and you wouldn't like
them applied to another situation again
this is a Socratic argument right so
Socrates was having a debate I think it
was with Alcibiades and he said
Alcibiades was putting forward the
argument that the life of physical
pleasure the life of pleasure is just
the very best life and everything else
is just goofy and ridiculous and
Socrates said hey man if they had a
really really bad itch and you can't get
to it for whatever reason and then you
finally get to it it's like oh that's so
good now there's a gift for you yeah and
that's a really really great feeling and
he's like well yeah and so Socrates says
okay so basically a life spent
perpetually scratching a perpetual itch
would be the very best life you know
read clearly is not very supportive also
if you can extract the principle well if
you're offended by something it should
be banished from your sight well clearly
that that is a very slippery slope and
so extracting the principle is really
important rather than what about this
statue and what about this statue and
what about this neighborhood I mean you
can't win that way any more than you can
do science by looking at one bouncing
ball all day well I say yeah I think
it's I remember reading that again not
in college we talked about Socrates
briefly and so I had a couple books on
Socrates actually from my um probably my
my favorite ones for my father my
grandfather in law who died he actually
fought in world war ii he was a mayor of
a Bloomfield Township in in in Michigan
and he had one that was specifically
dealing with the pro-life issue and it
was written from the perspective of
Socrates and an abortion doctor socrates
and abortion activist and I thought it
was a really good way to distill
sort of the Socratic method by taking
all different facets of voices of
opposition you know a doctor an activist
and it really did give me some insight
there why didn't I learn this in college
but but but you're right
those principles really do matter it's
the same thing where you're talking
about scratching an itch you know when
people say well you know we can we can
bring these these jobs back shovel-ready
jobs through a stimulus package well we
we could employ more people if we force
them to shovel with a spoon right it
that's certainly not something that
could be as easy as you say supported
logically same thing in Michigan there
are these trees we call them up North
trees and they're basically sticks with
a little little bit they're coniferous
so a little bit of needles at the top
and the reason for this is that this is
one of the biggest falsehoods that
Americans believe the the New Deal when
you look during the Great Depression all
of these jobs they just took people who
weren't qualified to perform jobs and
gave them tax dollars to perform jobs
that were useless and so we call them up
North trees and I only found this out
about five years ago it was just they
were jobs for people plant these trees
go up to the U P go up to northern
Michigan and plant these trees in and
will pay you and they had no idea how to
stagger the trees they didn't know where
to place them to the roots grew and
healthily so you have these rows and
rows of stick trees and you can see it
in real life and sometimes it's very
productive I found two point two
concrete examples that people can
observe today say this is the principle
and hey even if you go to Michigan
you'll see this do you think that's a
good thing and some of the forces on the
answer and they go well yes well no and
then they melts like the guy in Raiders
of the Lost Ark well yeah I mean
regarding things like minimum wage I
mean the old argument is well why $15
why not $1500 find out $15,000 an hour
and people at some point get that well
that's just gonna make people
unemployable aha or you know you you're
debating with somebody about the minimum
wage you say hey what do you do is like
well I'm a plumber it's like well okay I
support a minimum wage but only $500 an
hour for plumbers and you know only plum
only the person's like well actually
that cuz you know most of the people who
are debating minimum wage are not people
who are going to be subject to those
jobs another case is to say well what's
wrong with government schools that
someone comes out of 12 years of
Education only being worth $8 an hour I
mean what the hell is that what they
need not teaching people yeah in school
to make them economically
but the most fundamental final one is
sorry it's a violation of the
non-aggression principle if somebody
wants to hire somebody else for 8 bucks
an hour and that other person is willing
to work for that that is called a
voluntary transaction and if you
introduce a gun to that and say you can
only hire that person if you can pay
them $15 an hour
you've just initiated the use of force
in the in the environment of a peaceful
economic transaction that is immoral
because the initiation of force is wrong
absolute and that is a huge fundamental
difference between free enterprise and
socialism fascism communism and take
your ism of the day which Google will
undoubtedly never actually define as
left-wing economics by the way I don't
know if you know if you google fascism
says right-wing communism socialism no
mention of left-wing whatsoever but can
we do two minutes on the label thing oh
okay okay you tell what do you mean the
label thing on the fascism a little
thing like Oh Leo you were saying well
right-wing this that the other and of
course you know I I confound an annoy
everyone when it comes to my political
positions because you know try to reason
from first principles the philosopher
just always annoying because we evade
and escape labels because reasoning from
first principles is the key and you have
this all the time or its applied against
you it's applied against people say
far-right extreme this and what they do
is they create this category this is
sophistry 101 you create a category call
it you know flibbertigibbet whatever it
is and then you just like throwing darts
at a board you just attach relative
words to that category right this
negative worth nationalist supremacist
rate whatever it is right and then what
happens is you then attach that word to
a person whoo look at that and now all
of the negative connotations associated
with that category they're now stuck to
that person and they follow them around
like herpes and then you can just
dismiss everything that person says it's
a wonderful trap and a setup to allow
people to not evaluate arguments do not
evaluate positions to not process the
data of what someone's talking about and
that is fundamentally required because
we're taught so badly in government
schools we're not taught how to evaluate
an argument but we still need to make
decisions so we're desperate there's a
huge market for these negative labels
because people don't know how to
evaluate someone's argument but they
still need to make a decision so slander
on
fortunately is what rushes in when
people have not been taught how to think
yeah well the label for that right now
is all right right that's right right in
there yeah I mean you have Milo myself
Richard Spencer Jordan Peterson and Ben
Shapiro all get that same label no bit
severe Oh myself but very very active
well I will say this the contingent and
then philosophically sorry interruptus
no but philosophically the correct label
is Honka Soros and and people don't
really understand how that manly virile
bucket is where you all need to be
squished into well I was of this this is
one issue and that's why I say
right-wing I say conservative I say
constitutionalist because there is
certainly a portion of the all right
where I've argued with these people
where they've said well your
Constitution at this point we need to a
Constitution hasn't protected anything
it hasn't preserved anything and I don't
think that's mainstream necessarily all
right that is a wing of the alt right
because listen the fact that we're
having this conversation right now and
we cannot have it in the UK we cannot
have it to the same degree in Canada the
fact that people are allowed to get a
permit to even if they're white
nationalists or white supremacists or
whatever the most offensive category is
that day the the group is irrelevant I
always argue that again if we're going
to talk about principles contextually it
does matter where those principles come
from and as a country the United States
obviously the Constitution was a
recognition of inalienable rights were
not given to us by a government but by
god a creator which i think is
respectable for people even who are
atheist libertarians they have to
understand the main idea is it isn't
given to you by the government it's
merely a pass-through entity and that's
where I've argued with people on certain
I don't notice a certain portions wings
of the faroult right with the far left
with an toughie people who want to scrap
the Constitution if you do that it's
really difficult in the United States at
anyway to argue from first principles
and so that's something that I've
definitely taken upon myself on this
program to express is important that
preservation of the Constitution because
Canada is a quagmire because they don't
they don't view it the same way well I
mean if the Constitution hasn't
protected anything then why is what is
colloquially called hate speech I don't
know how and again hate speech itself is
just another one of these but yeah it's
yeah you know I mean the emotions of
someone you know I mean do you think
that the guys you know marching through
Frandsen in 1944-1945 I'm pretty sure
they didn't like the Nazis you know and
I think that there's a lot of people who
were myself included pretty damn good
that they didn't like the Nazis and so
the idea that you can attach a negative
word like hate to something called
speech that's not an argument that
America of course still has as a result
of the First Amendment hate speech is
protected speech again I don't even know
what hate speech I've never had a
convincing argument for somebody else
hey yeah I've never heard a convincing
argument for hate speech the they always
go to the argument the straw man if you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater
that's a call too and actually you can
yell fire in a crowded theater depending
on the context if you're saying hey that
that chicks on fire you might get
written up by HR that's different from
saying fire fire everybody run and you
could cause someone to get injured by a
call to action
it's the actionable offense there I've
never heard a convincing argument if I
were to have to take the other side with
hate speech I wouldn't be able to do it
because I've never heard a convincing
argument I've never heard convinced it's
a fire in the theater example the
problem is not that you're yelling fire
in a theater I mean if I'm the only guy
in a theater or maybe there's only one
other guy then maybe I've interrupted
the movie theater no one's know but the
movie no one's gotten hurt the problem
there is not that you yelling fire at a
crowded theater the problem is that
people are gonna die it's a
consequentialist argument right which
means that the hate aspect of it has
nothing to do I mean if I scream it's
the old thing if I scream some hateful
statement in the middle of a forest and
nobody hears what does it matter I mean
there's no content to the word hate no
intellectual content to the word hate
it's just a bucket to throw on popular
opinions in so people shy away from them
and the sad thing is is that if you if
you're facing someone who has really
terrible and egregious and horrible
opinions you should want them to speak
and show the world just how stupid they
are and how bad their arguments are and
it should be about as easy as pushing
over as Mike tights and taken on a girl
guide so I mean the idea that you've got
to have the government come in and call
in an airstrike on somebody making a
speech well if you're that bad at
rebutting it you shouldn't call the
government you should call me you should
pick up a copy of the art of the
argument should learn how to debate so
that you can be more effective and take
control of rebutting bad ideas under
your own control yeah absolutely thing
that's a good point and we're not even
to get into the idea of of hate crimes
you know murder doesn't need a footnote
that's one that's even a weaker
there is already a law in the book for
that crime like you said you're just
adding some arbitrary term at that point
hate to try and ascribe some kind of
particularly insidious motive or
intention that you could maybe tack
another tack another term on for it
really is silly and it's something that
a lot of people have taken at face value
let me ask you final question before we
have to go here now there are formidable
debaters out there there are people who
are great at it and there are people who
are ok at it our Great Debaters born or
are they made is it like you can train a
boxer but punchers are born do you think
that that people can become better for
who they are but maybe there are certain
limitations regardless of ability or
sort of I guess sort of techniques that
they're taught well I think it's like
pretty much any skill you know there are
certainly people who are born with a
particular desire and ability I mean I
first got into philosophy when I was 16
which is more years ago now than I
perhaps get a can't at the moment but so
it's like singing or it's like tennis I
mean there are some people who may be
sort of more naturally gifted although
if you look at people like Tiger Woods I
mean he was what was on the Carson show
with his his dad that strapped golf
clubs to his hands when he was like 2
years old I think the same thing was
true of Andre Agassi the the tennis
player his father was like I'm gonna
make you a tennis player and there's a
couple of female chess masters whose
fathers like well gonna make your chess
masters and here's what you do so I
don't know how far natural talent really
goes but everyone can improve and
everybody needs to improve I mean as you
know it's one thing to have debates you
know face to face in your personal life
or with somebody across a dinner table
you've got eye contact you've got the in
a tone of voice you've got all of that
kind of stuff on the internet things get
pretty crazy pretty quickly because
there's you know 90% of our
communication is nonverbal and so if you
are trying to have a debate online
you're trying to have a debate back and
forth and so on it's great because it's
public and you can really get some
you've got time to consider your points
and so on but you really really need to
be better we need to upper game as a
society when it comes to debating
because there's so many opportunities to
engage in public debate on Twitter on
Facebook on youtube comment sections who
are in your own podcasts or shows we
need to get better because the stakes
have never been
higher in terms of where we go as a
civilization to barbarity or to maintain
or expand the freedoms that we have but
also the opportunities and examples of
debating are so prevalent everywhere our
verbal cues our visual cues are
diminished we really have to return to
first principles build our arguments in
our cases up gradually and patiently and
in a listening way and recognize that
everybody who participates in a rational
debate win or lose everybody wins
because you know if you've beaten me in
the last debate I'd have come out with a
better perspective you know it's late
right you know if I'm about to take the
wrong medicine and you say staff that's
the wrong medicine the right medicine I
should say hey thanks man I really
really appreciate that and I think
that's what we should be aiming for or
you say yeah that's a party at the
hell's the difference and you take it
anyway all right the book is hold it up
for us one more time the art of the
debate what's I forgot of the argument
Martian civilizations last stand and the
website is part of the argument dot-com
and it's reasonably priced it's
entertaining it's engaging it's funny
and your life and your mind will never
be the same and it could depend on I
can't believe us the art of the debate
because it kept using the word debate
art of the argument calm stefan molyneux
like said everyone can certainly stand
to gain from this thank you so much for
being here brother people we make
something tomorrow it's a great pleasure
I appreciate them
[Music]